hello and welcome to another bitcoin
protocol explain tutorial video this
video is going to be covering
incentive so what is the incentive to
support and work with the network
as well as what's the incentive say you
have a lot of computing power to
overpower the network what's the
incentive of either working with the
network or overpowering the network
so let's go ahead and get started with
the paper by convention the first
transaction in a block is a special
transaction that starts a new coin owned
by the creator of that block
this adds an incentive for nodes to
support the network and provides a way
to initially distribute coins into
circulation since there is no central
authority to issue them
the steady addition of a constant amount
of new
coins is analogous to gold miners
expending resources to add gold into
circulation
in our case it's cpu time and
electricity that is expended
so here initially it's explained that
the incentive to be a part of the
network is to acquire
coins uh as a reward so this is also the
chosen method for coin distribution in
the network and as compared to people
you know using resources to like mine
something like gold
the main cost obviously here uh is going
to be cpu time and electricity so how
much electricity you have to pay for
so then the question is well what
happens in the year 2140
uh so in 2140 all of the coins will be
mined for bitcoin
um and so no coins will be awarded at
this point for actually supporting the
network
what if we don't even reach 2140 before
the amount of miners you know in the
network slows down
well continuing on in the paper the
incentive can also be funded with
transaction fees
if the output value of a transaction is
less than its input value the difference
is a transaction fee that is
added to the incentive value of the
block containing the transaction
once a predetermined number of coins
have entered circulation the incentive
can transition entirely
to transaction fees and be completely
inflation
free so the idea here is to move to
eventually move to a pure transactional
cost system
despite the sounding a lot like you know
like the current system we're in
uh where we've got you know two people
that want to transfer money we've got a
middleman that we've got to pay
it isn't quite the same this is still
very much peer-to-peer
and the transactional cost um would
really be a flat fee so first of all
your money isn't necessarily it's not
going to
filter through a third party so to speak
it's still going peer-to-peer
but you still need that middleman to
kind of like be like almost a notary to
say hey yeah these are the two real
people this is a real transaction taking
place
also the transactional cost would most
likely
be a flat fee you wouldn't pay like a
percentage um
on the you know transaction amount it
would be a flat fee
um so really you know with bitcoin
we're talking probably one to three
dollars right to make a transfer
uh at most so right now competition for
mining and all this is extremely high
for people to acquire coins but when
coins are no longer being distributed
or if they begin to lose value the
actual hash you know difficulty is going
to drop
and so it would simply just become
easier so whether or not you have 500
000 miners or 50 000 miners
you're going to notice relatively
similar results when it comes to
transaction speed and all of that
the only threat here is that if the
number of miners was to actually drop
someone could more easily come in and
execute a 51
attack at which point the question is
would it still
not be worth um attacking the network
and we will hit this question again in a
moment but for now let's go ahead and
return to the paper
the incentive may help encourage nodes
to stay honest if a greedy attacker is
able to assemble
more cpu power than all the honest nodes
he would have to choose between using it
to defraud people by stealing back his
payments
or using it to generate new coins he
ought to find it more profitable to play
by the rules such rules that favor him
with
more new coins than everyone else
combined
than to undermine the system and
validity of his own wealth
so here's expressed why 51 attack even
if someone had the resources
doesn't really make that much sense
there's more incentive financially to
actually work with the network
um and if the incentive was just like
plain malicious to like kill the network
or something
then this would prove to be a pretty
costly endeavor
um so neither of those options are
really good
options now again this is where the
question is asked whether or not the
network will still be as secured as it
is today
by 2140 and secure as in a relative to
you know the day's mining power see here
i think it's there's a little less
certainty about security is mining
will be more about transaction fees
rather than actually acquiring coins now
keep in mind that every 10 minutes
25 bitcoin is released right now that's
worth
20 000 right every 10 minutes
so to match today's level of security or
better put
to to match today's challenge and reward
in relation to cpu power of the day
you'd need twenty thousand dollars every
ten minutes worth of transaction rewards
or transaction fees
so 120 000 an hour 2.9 million dollars a
day or just
over one billion dollars a year in
transactional
cost you know fees basically
now obviously um this is measured of
course in today's terms as well since
inflation will probably make these
numbers way bigger and to be at the same
level of security so you know as the
average computer gets faster i mean this
is all relative since breaching or
working for the network it's all going
to be in relation
to that day's current cpu standard you
know
um now that said really by 2140
so we're talking over you know a century
okay it's highly likely first of all
that there will one be a quantum
computer
it's really really unlikely that bitcoin
as we know it today will still be
trucking along by then
we're talking over a century from the
point of its development
so first off who even knows like we it's
also highly likely we'll have like
killed
each other by then but also um i don't
know any technology that hasn't
you know had to be evolved within a
century's time i mean if you just look
at you know sha-1 versus sha-256 we
already know that there are
there's security differences between the
two of them
and that's just based on the cpu growth
over time now
um i do think that all that said it's
something to consider at least though
you know that like you know consider by
2140 the question of security
but i honestly think at least my
argument is that there's no point in
thinking that far out to 2140
as by then the game is going to have
changed
significantly and we'll all be trading
like quantum coins or something like
that
so um also
i i will just there will be another
video pretty much dedicated
towards this specific uh thing as far as
how bitcoin will evolve or can bitcoin
evolve
uh over time i'll give you guys a hint
yes um
and and actually it can evolve within
the system of
bitcoin itself because bitcoin is really
one big voting scheme
um it's really one big cp one cpu one
vote
um structure and so really anything can
occur
within the realm of one cpu one vote
here so
um bitcoin can evolve and i
pretty much guarantee it um that it will
evolve by 2140. i'll bet my
my whole bank account because by then
i'll be dead anyways and so will
everyone watching this
but anyway uh that's going to conclude
the incentive tutorial video
basically the takeaway here is that
there's at least right now a large
incentive to mine
as we already know the difficulty of
mining is systematic and it changes
based on the amount of miners mining
so it's always going to be the case at
least until 2140
that it's going to make fiscal sense
more fiscal sense to mine for the
network
than to attack the network especially
because if you attack the network
you're going to like first of all it's
going to be very costly
and versus if you work for the network
we're talking you know if you let's say
you had over 50
of the network well that means every 10
minutes you're going to get a 50 50
chance of getting those coins
so we're talking every 10 minutes well
every hour you would make 60 000 every
hour
you know with your 50 50 odds so
uh i would think that it would be in
your favor to go ahead and work for the
network
so um so that's it if you have any
questions or comments feel free to leave
them below
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support in the subscriptions and
until
the next video